est-ce qu'on peut utiliser un vélo
normal pour faire du bmx non parce que
le vélo normal il va être trop grand
romain racines et double champion de
france junior de bmx
face à lui des enfants qui découvrent la
discipline c'est transmettre une passion
que certains satin pas forcément la
chance d'avoir dans son moi j'ai fait du
vélo tous les jours et c'est un plaisir
on leur présente directement une journée
type d'un athlète
comment il vit ici au centre et quelle
est sa discipline et qu'est ce qu'il
doit faire
et qu'est-ce qu'il fait pendant ces
entraînements c'est 35 enfants ont vécu
une journée autour du cyclisme
ils ont pu visiter le vélodrome assister
à des entraînements mais aussi se tester
le matin ils ont fait leur baptême de
bmx s'est pas trop trop facile mais ça
va je me suis blessé deux fois et après
c'était bien ça va j'ai appris des des
choses pour un home by mx pour voûté
toul l'objectif de la journée était de
permettre à des enfants qui n'ont pas la
possibilité de pouvoir avoir accès aux
loisirs au sport de la barre une journée
détente pendant les vacances et donc en
partenariat avec le vélodrome
national de saint quentin en yvelines et
la communauté d'agglo de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines de pouvoir
leur permettre d'avoir une initiation de
baptême de bmx en fait ministre bmx une
visite du vélodrome
chaque année le secours populaire fait
découvrir la discipline à des enfants
yvelinois issus de milieux modestes
une découverte du sport comme moyen de
réduire les inégalités et pourquoi pas
susciter des vocations